insan insan
ve yine insan bu biraz daha çöp adam
olmuş ama bunu da insan kabul edelim
Peki insanı Hatta canlıları varlık yapan
şey nedir
bizleri varlık yapan şey
biraz Göreceli bir cevap vereceğim Ancak
bu sorunun cevabı bence kalptir yani
vicdandır Peki bu cevabı cebimize atalım
ve insanı Çöp adamdan devam edelim
Siz kendisine bir isim seçelim hemen
Mesela Arda nasıl olur istemiyor Peki
besin nasıl olur beğendiğim Tamam onu da
istemiyorsun Pekala şuna ne dersin Cesur
cesuru Sevdin Mi Sevdin Pekala o zaman
sana bundan sonra Cesur diyelim cesuru
biraz tanıyalım isterseniz Cesur Aslında
biz İnsanlara çok benziyor sabah 8 akşam
5 mesai saatleri vardır erken yatar
erken kalkar işine gider gücüne bakar bu
Aslında her insanın Aynı olmasa da
benzer şartlardaki yaşamını temsil eder
Öyle değil mi Cesur ise bir gün bu
düzenden sıkılıyor ve insanlar
çalışmamalı gibi
ütopik bir fikir ortaya atıyor gayet
iddialı olmalıdır herhalde Cesur iyice
düşünüp taşınıyor ve çareyi insanların
yerini alabilme kapasitesinde olan bir
takım robotlar üretmekte buluyor Evet
robotlar
cesuru çok çalışkan ve bir o kadar da
zekiydi uğraştı çabaladı Emek verdi
insan gücüyle yepyeni bir robot
tasarladı ve o robotu da hayata geçirdi
Ancak bu robotu seri üretime geçirmek
biraz zaman isteyen bir süreçti Cesur bu
süreç içerisinde robotuna baktığı
büyüttüğü geliştirdiği kolladı Cesur
öyle bir robot yapmıştı ki bu robot
bırakın Fiziksel hareketlerde bulunmayı
hem konuşabiliyor hem de düşünebiliyordu
Cesur bu dünyadaki gelmiş geçmiş en
kültürlü en Bilge ve en ünlü robotu
çoktan yaratmıştı bile
evetime geçirdi Çünkü bir hedefi vardı
gereksiz işlerde çalışmamak Cesur iyice
önüne ün kapmaya başlamış ve arkasını
belli bir kitleyi toplamayı başarmıştı
resmen insanların umudu olmuş büyük ses
getiren çalışmalara imza atmıştı ancak
hiç sıkıntı vardı Cesur ve bütün
insanlar şunu unutmuştu insanların çok
büyük bir zafiyeti vardı o da
sorumluluklarını ve işlerine En kısa
yoldan halletme ve özgür kalma isteğiydi
insanlar robotlar üretilince çalışmak
zorunda kalmadılar çünkü robotlar
onların yapabileceği her şey
yapıyorlardı zaten ve insanlar artık
özgürdü Ancak bu özgürlük öyle bir
özgürlüktü ki insanlar her şeyi
yapabilirlerdi ancak hiçbir şey yapmamak
insanlara daha yazıp geliyordu Cesur
dışarıya bakınca hiçbir insanı göremedi
adeta bir robotlar istilasındaydı
ürettiği robotlar insanları Her ne kadar
sabah 8 akşam 5 misallerinden
kurtarmışsa da insan neslini
tembelleştirmişti cesur ürettiği
robotların ne kadar donanımını ve ne
kadar zeki olduğunu fark edince kendine
soruyu sordu Benim yarattığım bir şey
nasıl benden daha zeki olabilir
Tamam kabul ediyorum Bu biraz
ütopik ve Klişe bir senaryoydu Sonuçta
robotların gelişiminden endişelenen
herkes buna benzer senaryoları
anlatırlar ve abartmayı da severler
doğrusu
duyarsınız işte ya her yerde robotlar
dünyayı hükmedecek falan
Peki
ütopik diyoruz ama ne kadar ütopik
sormak istiyorum insan yapımı bir robot
nasıl yaratıcı düşünüp cevap verebilir
işte burada karşımıza çıtayı adlı bir
Yapay Zeka ortaya çıkıyor
herkesin kullanımına açık ve her şeyi
bilebilen bir yapay zekadır Mesela bir
Ödeviniz mi var Boş verin Yapmayın bu
ödevinizi seçip bir şey yaptırarak bu
ödevlerinizden kurtulabilirsiniz veya
bir sorunuz mu var bu soruyu seçip diye
sorarak anında cevap alabilirsiniz ya da
diyelim ki sıkıldınız gerçeği ile sohbet
edebilirsiniz Çünkü kendisi çok
kültürlüdür aynı zamanda
dediğim gibi kullanımı Tamamen açık ve
size kalmıştır meziyetle çok yönlü Bilge
kültürlü bir Yapay Zeka
Aslında daha da önemli bir şey var Cat
gpt 4-5 ay içerisinde 4-5 ay içerisinde
bilgi dağarcanı ve özelliklerini resmen
ikiye üçe katlan nitelikte kendini
geliştirdi önceden teknoloji yıllar
içerisinde gelişirken artık aylar
içerisinde gelişmeye başladı bu kademeli
bir gelişmeler ziyade adeta bir sıçra
yaşa dönüştü gelişmenin Ayak seslerini
size Duyabiliyor musunuz
Aslında insanlar kontrollü bir şekilde
gelişirse teknolojiyi kendi çıkarları
lehine kullanabilirler Elbette mesela
teknoloji bize günlük hayatımızda zaten
yardım etmiyor mu örneğin
navigasyonlarda internet sitelerinde
cihazlarda ve hatta en önemlisi bilimsel
araştırmalarını bize yardım etmiyorlar
mı Biz dünyamızı kurtarmak için gereken
önlemleri bilgisayarlarla hesaplarken
Aynı zamanda da eğer bu yaşadığımız
dünyayı kurtaramazsak eğer Hangi
gezegenin Bizim için en iyi şartlara
sahip olduğunu araştırabiliyoruz ve
teknolojinin sıçraya sıçrayı geliştiği
bir dünyada bilimsel araştırmalarda daha
da fazla hız kazandı Elbette şu anda
medeniyetlerin gelişmişliği Arge ve
teknoloji gücüyle ölçülmeye başlandı
böyle bir ortamda ise rekabette haliyle
fazla oluyor bu rekabeti ise insanlar
olarak lehimize mi yoksa aleyhimize mi
kullandığımız meçhul mesela yapılan bir
araştırmaya göre
Küçük işletmelerin %31'i çoktan Yapay
Zeka araçlarını kullanmaya başlamışlar
ve bu %31'lik kesmin yüzde seksenikilik
kısmı bu Yapay Zeka araçları sayesinde
daha fazla gelire ve daha az gidere
sahip olmuşlar gördüğünüz gibi yapay
zekalar Küçük işletmelerin ekonomik
verimliliğini arttırmış Aslında bu
insanların lehine olan bir şey öyle
değil mi ancak yine yapılan bir
araştırmaya göre
2030 yılına kadar robotların insan
emeğinin yüzde otuzunu alacağı tahmin
ediliyor İşte ben bu insan emeği
kısmında sizleri bir yapay zekadan daha
bahsetmek istiyorum
Kendisi Burada da görebileceğiniz üzere
illüstrasyonlar ve bir o kadar da
yaratıcı resimler yapmakla meşhur Peki
sormak istiyorum
kendi isteğiniz neticesinde resimlerini
Duygu da katabildiğiniz bir Yapay Zeka
varken ressamlara ne gerek var
ressamlar bizi yeteri kadar tatmin
etmiyor mu peki bu Yapay Zeka yani Dali
gerçekten de ihtiyacımız olan bir Yapay
Zeka mı insanlığın ihtiyacı olan bir
yapay Zekamı senin anlattıkların robot
değil ki Yapay Zeka bunlar hayır bu
saydığım bütün yapay zekalar elbet bir
gün ileride robotlarda kullanılacak ve
böyle bir durumda ise insanlar ve
robotlar beraber yaşayacaklar
ben bu beraber yaşama konusunda sizleri
birisinden bahsedeceğim kanal Max
karmaksa eminim bilen Çoğu kişi vardır
Ancak ben yine de söyleyeyim kendileri
19 yüzyılda yaşamış alınan bir Filozof
ve bilimsel sosyalizmin de kurucusu
olurlar
diyalektik materyalizmde bir görüşü
savunur Karlar diyalektik kelimesi
yabancı gelmesin hemen anlatalım
diyalektik düşünce üç bölüme ayrılır tez
antiez
Bunlar nedir hemen Şöyle özetleyebilirim
mesela bir etkinliğe gittiğinizi düşünün
O gün o etkinliği hazırlayanlar yani
organizatörler o gün en yetkili kişiler
olacakları için onlar tez olsun Siz ise
etkinliği kuranların karşıtı Yani bir
katılımcı olarak oraya gittiğiniz için
siz tezin karşıtı olan antisez oldunuz
ve ne hikmetse iki grubunda orada
bulunuş amaçları farklı olsa da bir
mekan altında buluşmayı başarmışlar İşte
o mekanda sentez oluyor bakın eğer tez
olanlar yani etkinliği hazırlayanlar
olmasaydı eğer belki de siz o gün oraya
gitmeyecektiniz ve belki de o mekanın
altında buluşamayacaktınız Demek ki
neymiş tez diğerlerini tetiklermiş
şu demektir maddeyi duyulan inanç
demektir Her şeyin maddeden
gelmektedirler bu kadar bilseniz
yeterdir Özünde kazma diğer elektrik
materyalizmde şunu anlatmaktadır
toplumda bir tez vardır ve bu test Soylu
sınıftır toplumda bir antiez vardır ve
bu antitez halktır toplumda bir sentez
vardır Hem tezin hem de antiezin
birleştiği bir yer İşte orası da
mekanlardır Soylu sınıfı halkı Manipüle
eder halk bu manipülasyona İnanır ve
Soylu sınıf bu manipülasyonun
nimetlerini yer Bu üçü de birbirimize
zincirleme bağlanmıştır ve birbirinden
ayrılamazlar
Mesela bu şemayı hatta günlük
hayatımızda patron işçi fabrika olarak
ya da müdür beyaz yakalı Plaza olarak da
düşünebilirsiniz
tez antitez ve sentezi işte biraz
anladığınız anladıysak Eğer cebimize
atalım ve biraz daha derinlere inelim
cesuru tekrardan gelsin cesuru Yani
aslında biz insanları doğadaki
hayvanlardan ayıran temel farklılıklar
nedir çok sorulan bir düşünce sorusudur
böyle değil mi Mesela bu farklılıklar
yaratıcı düşünebilme yeteneği olabilir
ya da irade sahibi olmamız olabilir
Özgür olmamız olabilir analiz
yapabilmemiz aklı kullanarak düşünmemiz
Bunlar Olabilir Öyle değil mi ancak
mesela duygularımız bir farklılık
değildir Sonuçta hayvanların da duygusu
Vardır onların da vicdanı vardır
Peki hayvanlara özgü özellik nedir
mesela Bence bu doğal durumunda
olmalarıdır Öyle değil mi Çünkü eğer
hayvanları karışan bir etki yoksa eğer
onlar zaten kafasına göre takılıyor Peki
hiç kendinizi şunu sordunuz mu Biz
insanları robotlardan ayıran temel
farklılıklar nedir mesela chat gpitiyle
güçlendirilmiş bir robot düşünelim
yaratıcı düşünebilme yeteneği bir
farklılık olabilir mi Hayır Olamaz Peki
analiz yapabilmek mi farklılık olacak mı
hayır üzgünüm O da olmayacak bizim
farklılıklarımız duygularımız
irade sahibi olmamız ve özgür olmamız
olacak çünkü robotlar insanlardan
gelecekte daha da Kıvrak düşünecek
Çünkü ben şemasına baktığınızda da fark
edebileceğiniz üzere zaten bizim hem
hayvanlarla hem de robotlarla ortak bir
özelliğimiz olmayacak yani bu 3 grubunda
ortak bir özelliği olmayacak Eğer bir
gün robotlarda yaşarsa ki ben Murat
ihtimal vermiyorum o zaman bu şema
değişir ve dünya yeni bir varlık kazanır
Çünkü konuşmanın başında da en başında
da dediğim gibi sizlere bizleri varlık
yapan esas özellik Vicdanlı oluşumuzdur
Peki bütün insanların patron olduğu
robotların da varlık olarak yaşadığı bir
dünyayı Hayal edelim Bu dünyada tez
antitez ve Sentez ne olurdu şimdi
düşünelim Bir bütün insanlar bir kere
patron olacağı için büyük ihtimalle
Şüphesiz ki insanlar tez olacaktı
antide ise insanların karşıtı olan
robotlar olacaktı Öyle değil mi peki
Sentez ne olurdu işte bu konuda insanlar
ikiye ayrılıyor bir kesin robotların
varlığından şüphelenirken diğer kesim Bu
şüphelerin tamamen gereksiz olduğunu
vurgulamakta Tamam kabul ediyorum ben
gelecekleri kestirmek her ne kadar zor
olsa da eğer hakikat olan bir sentezle
buluşamıyorsak bize nasıl bir gelecek
bekliyor insanlar robotlar konusunda
ölçülü mü davranacaklar yoksa bildikleri
yoldan şaşmayacaklar mı
insan insan insan insan
bu defa insan aynı cesuru sorduğu gibi
bir soru sorarken kendine Benim
yarattığım bir şey nasıl benden daha
zeki olabilir bu soru ilk kim sormuştu
biliyor musunuz Tanrı
teşekkür ederim